مساء الخير مشاهدينا انا ميسون ويهد
احييكم واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه نبدا
بالعناوين
وفدت جمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعات
مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه خطوه مقابله
خطوه تعيد دمشق الى الحضن العربي بشروط
والجامعه العربيه ترحب بمشاركه الاسد
بالقمه اذا رغب
القضاء العراقي يصدر حكما بالاعدام
علاقاتل هشام الهاشمي ودعوات لمعرفه من
اصدر الاوامر
واستطلاع لواشنطن بوست واي بي سي يظهر
تراجع شعبيه بايدن بعد قراره الترشح
لولايه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه بعد غياب طال
سنوات وفي اجتماع استثنائي عقده مجلس
الجامعه العربيه على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه
في القاهره وافق وزراء الخارجيه العرب على
عوده المشروطه لسوريا الى جامعه الدول
العربيه بعد 12 سنه من الانقطاع قرار
العوده قضى بتشكيل لجنه وزاريه مكونه من
السعوديه والاردن ومصر والعراق ولبنان
والامين العام لمتابعه تنفيذ بيان عمان
والاستمرار بالحوار المباشر مع دمشق اضافه
الى استئناف مشاركه الوفود السوريه في
اجتماعات مجلس الجامعه وجميع المنظمات
والاجهزه التابعه لها اعتبارا من اليوم
القرار جدد ايضا الالتزام بالحفاظ على
سياده سوريا ووحده اراضيها كما شدد القرار
على ضروره اتخاذ خطوات عمليه وفاعله
للتدرج نحو حل الازمه السوريه وفق مبدا
الخطوه مقابل الخطوه بدوره اكد وزير
الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري ان الحسم
العسكري بسوريا امر غير واقعي ويجب ايجاد
تسويه سياسيه
لان السبيل الوحيد للتسويه هو الحل
السياسي بملكيه سوريه خالصه دون املاءات
خارجيه
واستيفاء الاجراءات المرتبطه بتحقيق
التوافق الوطني بين الاشقاء السوريين
وبناء الثقه ومواصله اجتماعات اللجنه
الدستوريه على نحو يتمشى مع المرجعيات
الدوليه وقرار مجلس الامن رقم 22 54
وبما يلبي تطلعات الشعب السوري ويحقق
اماله المشروع في غدا افضل
ويضمن الحفاظ على وحده
سوريا وسيادتها وسلامتها الاقليميه
وعروباتها وينهي كل مظاهر التدخلات
الخارجيه في شؤونها بما في ذلك الاعتداءات
على اراضيها
واعقل عن الجامعه العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
ان قرار اعاده سوريا للجامعه العربيه
عاده الدول العربيه لعلاقاتها مع سوريا
مشيرا الى ان هذا قرار سيادي تتخذه كل
دوله
عوده سوريا الى شغل المقعد
هي بدايه حركه وليست نهايه مطاف بمعنى انه
مسار التسويه للازمه السوريه حتاخذ مرحله
من الاجراءات والتدرج فيها ومهمه هذه
اللجنه هي متابعه هذه
الاجراءات ايضا هي ليس
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سيادي لكل دوله على حده
نحن نتحدث في هذا القرار عن
شغل المقعد وتشكيل اللجنه للتواصل مع
الحكم في سوريا
ابو الغيط اضافه ان الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد من حقه المشاركه في اجتماع القمه
المقبل للجامعه العربيه اذا رغب في ذلك
سوريا
ابتداء من مساء اليوم هي عدوه كامل
العضويه بالجامعه العربيه ومن صباح غد لهم
الحق في شغل اي مقعد يشاركون فيه عندما
توجه الدعوه من قبل الدوله الضيافه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واذا ما رغب ان
يشارك فسوف يشارك
تعود سوريا الى الحضن العربي لكنها لن
تعود لنفسها بسهوله فهي بحاجه لاكبر
فاتوره اعمار في التاريخ الحديث قدرتها
الجامعه العربيه
بتسعمئه مليار دولار بينما توقعت بعض
المنظمات الامميه ان تصل التكلفه الى 450
مليارا رقم كبير يحتاجه السوريون لازاله
الاثار المباشره اثني عشر عاما من الحرب
هذه الازمه التي امتدت تبع عيرتها السلبيه
من ارهاب ودمار ونزوح ولجوء الى سائر دول
المنطقه والعالم
نحو نصفي سكان سوريا بحاجه لمساعدات عاجله
12 مليون مواطن اجبروا على الفرار من
بيوتهم نصفهم نزح داخل البلاد والنصف
الاخر اصبح حبيس مخيمات اللجوء في الدول
المجاوره او رفضته امواج البحر الى دول
العالم
وقد تنجح ورشه اعمار دوليه مع استثمار
فعال لموارد سوريا في اعاده بناء البلاد
خلال سنوات طويله قادمه لكن الخسائر
البشريه والهدم الذي جرى في النفوس يستحيل
بناؤه
احبائه واقرباء واهل فقدوا في مسلسل قتل
طال نحو 350 الف شخص بينهم 300 الف مدني
على الاقل
من دمشق ينضم الينا عمر رحمون المتحدث
باسم المصالحه السوريه سيد رحمون اهلا بكم
معنا سوريا استعادت مقعدها في الجامعه
العربيه هل الرئيس الاسد سيحضر القمه
تحيه للساده المشاهدين طبعا هذا خبر جيد
اليوم عوده سوريا لمقعدها في الجامعه
العربيه وهو الخبر الابرز والاهم عربيا
عوده سوريا لمقعدها وفتح العرب بابهم
لسوريا اما موضوع حضور السيد الرئيس القمه
هذا طعن برسم القياده السوريه حتى الان
هذا شيء لم يتم التصريح عنه بامكان الدوله
ان يحضر السيد الرئيس او ان ينيب وزير
الخارجيه هذا برسم الدوله السوريه حتى
الان لا يوجد اي اشاره على حضور السيد
الرئيس او حضور من يونيب عنه اذا اراد ان
يجيب عنه وزير الخارجيه او حتى نائب
الرئيس طب الان دمشق قادته الى الجامعه
العربيه ولكن كيف ستتعامل من اجل عوده
العلاقات مع كل الاشقاء العرب ما هي
المسؤوليات الملقات الان على سوريا
لا شك بان العوده الى جامعه الدول العربيه
هو حدث مهم وحدث له قيمته عربيا لكن نحن
في سوريا على لسان المسؤولين اكدوا اكثر
من مره بان العلاقات العربيه الثنائيه هي
اهم من العوده الى جامعه الدول العربيه
وبالتالي كان هناك عمل نشيط بين سوريا
وبين الدول وفي الحقيقه العلاقات الثنائيه
لم تبقى منقطعه الا ما عدد قليل جدا مع
هذه الدول مثل قطر والمغرب اما بقيه الدول
العربيه السفارات السوريه مفتوحه
مفتوحه في الدول العربيه وسفارات الدول
العربيه مفتوحه في سوريا لكن بقي فقط
تتويج هذا
الثنائيه هو عوده
انا في
هذا السيد
رحمون اعذرني يتقطع صوتك وخساره كذلك لانه
كما شاهدنا
نعم الان اسمعك تفضل
تمام يعني غياب العرب عن سوريا خساره
للعرب وخساره لسوريا كلنا شاهدنا بانه
خلال الفتره السابقه
عندما تغيب العرب عن سوريا كانت
الاجتماعات سواء كان في
اجتماع روسيا وايران وتركيا اما العرب اين
العنصر العربي يعني غياب العرب عن سوريا
هو فيه ضرر للعرب وللسوريا الان فتحنا
صفحه جديده هناك فتح صفحه جديده صفحه سيد
رحمون ايضا يجب ان يجب ان ايضا ان تشمل
الداخل السوري وهو الاهم وهو المصالحه
وحضرتك مسؤول يعني بهذا الملف وموضوع الحل
السياسي الداخلي في سوريا
دون ادنى شك لانها انا على قراءه العربيه
والكثير من القنوات كنت انادي بفتح
المعابر بين شمال السوري لكي يعود الناس
الذين تختطفهم جبهه النصره لكن في الحقيقه
منذ اربع سنوات حتى الان
المعابر بين ادلب وبين حلب مغلقه بقرار
تركي ليس بقرار سوري يعني نحن لا نريد ان
نلقي
باللوم على سوريا ونترك بقيه الاطراف
سوريا نعم نحن مع عوده النازحين نحن معوده
اللاجئين سوريا من واجبها ان تفتح ابوابها
بغض النظر عن موضوع المعابر الداخل السوري
واين وصلت هذه المصالحه مع من تتحدثون
المعارضه مثلا هناك ايضا فصائل كثيره هل
انتم منفتحون على كل هذه الفصائل على كل
المعارضه السوريه حتى يعود هؤلاء اللاجئين
والنازحين
استاذه
يبدو يبدو باننا فقدنا على كل حال رايتما
يعود معنا سيد رحمون سنتوقف مع موضوع ملف
عوده اللاجئين السوريين الى بلادهم احد
اولويات مناقشات عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه ووفق احصائيات المنظمات الانسانيه
والاماميه تتصدر تركيا قائمه الدول
المستضيفه للاجئين السوريين حيث اعلنت
اداره الهجره التركيه ان اعداد السوريين
تحت الحمايه المؤقته وصل الى اكثر من
ثلاثه ملايين وسبعمائه الف حتى الثامن
والعشرين من ابريل 2020 بعد تركيا ياتي
لبنان الذي يبلغ عدد اللاجئين السوريين
فيه 840 الف لاجئ فيما عدد السوريين في
لبنان بالمجمل يتجاوز المليونين حسب
احصائيات الامم المتحده في الاردن من اصل
نحو مليون و300 الف سوري يقيمون على
اراضيه سجلت المفوضيه الامميه للاجئين نحو
800 الف لاجئ ويستضيف العراق قرابه 260
الف لاجئ سوري يسكن غالبيتهم في اقليم
كردستان اما مصر فصنفت المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره السوريين فيها كمهاجرين ويبلغ
عددهم مليونا وخمسمائه الف
مره جديده اعود اليكم عمر رحمون المتحدث
باسم المصالحه السوريه استاذ عمر الاهم هو
موضوع اللاجئين والمهجرين اين وصلت هذه
المصالحه مع من تتحدثون ما هي طبيعه هذه
المصالحه ومتى سيعودون ما هي الاليه حتى
يعودوا بامن الى الداخل السوري
سيدتي لا شك بان عوده النازحين او
اللاجئين ناجحين في داخل سوريا او
اللاجئين من خارج سوريا هذا يعني امر
ضروري جدا ومطلب لسوريا وحتى للدول
المجاوره اما موضوع المصالح نحن الباب
مفتوح باب المصالحه مفتوح ان هناك حل
سياسي هناك تسويه سياسيه للازمه بشكل عام
وهناك مصالحه للناس لمن يرغب ان يعود الى
بيته الى مدينته الى ارضه لكي يزاول مهنته
فهذا الباب مفتوح لكن
هناك ست ملايين نازح
نازح بين لاجئ ليس كلها مطلوبين في قسم
مطلوب ممن حمل السلاح اما النازحين
العاديين والمواطنين بامكانهم ان يعودوا
الى بيوتهم دون ان يتعرض لهم احد طب الذين
حملوا السلاح كيف ستتعاملون معهم
نتعامل معهم كما تعاملنا مع الفصائل في
درعا الفصائل في درعا والفصائل في الرستن
في تلبيسه في حمص هناك فصائل صالحت وبقيت
في بيوتها وحتى هذه اللحظه هؤلاء في
بيوتهم
يمارسون اعمالهم بكل اريحيه ولا يوجد اي
مضايقات عليهم يعني هذا الموضوع يضخم
اعلاميا بحاجه
شكرا لك عمر رحمون المتحدث باسم المصالح
السوريه كنت معي من دمشق
[موسيقى]
وجه العهد السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
مركز الملك سلمان الاغاثه بتقديم مساعدات
انسانيه متنوعه بقيمه 100 مليون دولار
لصالح الشعب السوداني كما وجه الملك سلمان
والامير محمد بن سلمان بتنظيم حمله شعبيه
عبر منصه ساهم وذلك لتخفيف اثار الاوضاع
التي يمر بها الشعب السوداني حاليا
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من المحادثات الجاريه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريه في جده
والهدن المتتاليه المعلنه لم تتوقف
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم فطرفان وفق الخبراء
لم يسبق لهما خوض حرب شوارع في عاصمه ولا
يستطيع احد منهما حسمها سريعا وبالتالي
يسود قلق من ان تطول الحرب فوجود قدرات
متساويه بين طرفي الصراع الى جانب الاجلاء
العديد من الاجانب واستعداد اخرين لمغادره
السودان يحتمل ان يكون الطرفان يتحضران
لصراعا طويل الامد من اجل السيطره على
البلاد
بينما تعمل الوسطات الدوليه والاقليميه
على التهدئه السياسيه بين طرفي النزاع في
السودان تعكس المجريات على الارض صوره
مختلفه فالقتال في السودان ما زال مستمرا
رغم الهدنه الطويله لتسمع اصوات
الاشتباكات جنوب ووسط العاصمه الخرطوم
بالاخص في منطقه السوق العروي ومحيط
المطار وافاد شهود عيان بتحليق طائرات
حربيه وسماع يدوي انفجار قوي واصوات اسلحه
ثقيله في محيط القصر الرئاسي والقياده
العامه للجيش كما شنت الطائرات ضربات جويه
في حي الرياض بالخرطوم لم ينحصر باستمرار
الصراع في تلك المنطقه بل سمع دوي
انفجارات وتحليق للطيران الحربي في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري واشتباكات متفرقه في منطقتي
كافوري وشرق النيل بالاضافه لاصوات مضادات
الطيران في اندرمان
اتهامات متبادله بين الطرفين النزاع بخرق
الهدنه فالجيش السوداني اتهم قوات الدعم
السريع بارسال تعزيزات للخرطوم بينما اكدت
الجهه الاخرى شن غارات من قبل الجيش
السوداني على مناطق لقوات الدعم السريع
والتي بدورها حاولت استهداف قياده قوات
الدفاع الجوي
وفي ظل الاشتباكات المستمره فتح الباب
امام عمليات النهب والحرق على وجه الخصوص
في المنطقه الصناعيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
وضع يعكس تصريحات طرفي الصراع باستعدادهما
لمناقشه الهدنه والوضع الانساني دون
الالتزام بوقف النهائي لاطلاق النار ايفا
عمر العربيه
في وقت تستمر التقييمات للقوتين
المتسارعتين على الارض اكد مركز
وانترناشونال
عدم استخدام الجيش السوداني لكامل قوته
ولا سيما الجويه منها فالجيش السوداني هو
سابع اقوى جيش في افريقيا والسادس من حيث
العدد في القاره السمراء فهو يمتلك 191
طائره حربيه لكنها لم تثبت فعاليتها بعد
لسببين اولهما عدم القدره على تحديد
الاهداف بدقه لغياب معلومات قويه على
الارض او عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه وفق
مركزي البحث اما ثاني الاسباب فهو تحييد
المدنيين لان الجيش لا يستطيع القاء قنابل
بكثافه في اي مكان في الخرطوم خوفا من
اصابات بصفوف مدنيين فيما تتمتع الدعم
السريع من جهتها بالقدره على التحرك
السريع بعربات خفيفه في ثلاث مناطق بسبب
مرور فرعين نيل الازرق والابيض وهي
الخرطوم جنوبا والخرطوم بحري في الشمال
وام درمان في الشمال الشرقيه
اعلن وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري
تشكيل لجنه اتصال عربيه خاصه بالسودان
لوقف القتال وضمان سلامه الممرات الامنه
في البلاد نتابع
هناك اهميه وضروره بالغه للتحرك العربي
السريع والمؤثر حاليا ومن هنا جاء قرار
انشاء لجنه اتصال من بين اعضاء الجامعه
العربيه
تهدف لوقف اطلاق النار والسماح بالممرات
الانسانيه لاحتياجات المدنيين والحفاظ على
مؤسسات الدوله وعدم تعريضها للخطر
الانهيار الذي يهددها حاليا
عددت صحيفه واشنطن مجموعه من الاخطاء التي
وقعت فيها الولايات المتحده بخصوص تعاملها
مع البرهان وحماتي حينما لم تقم بفرض
عقوبات عليهما بعد اطاحتهما بالحكومه
المدنيه عام 2021 ما اوصل السودان الى بلد
يواجه الحرب الاهليه نتابع
من بلد يسال الديمقراطيه الى مواجهه الحرب
الاهليه من البحث عن الحريه والدوله
المدنيه الى البحث عن مكان امن يقي من نار
الحرب وشدتها هكذا اصبح حال السودانيين
فحتى في ظل الاجواء التي تلت الاطاحه
بالنظام عمر البشير كانت بذور الصراع
الحالي قد زرعت بالفعل في تربه البلاد
اخطاء مفصليه في تعامل واشنطن مع السودان
عددتها صحيفه واشنطن بوست ابرز هذه
الاخطاء تتمثل في فشل الولايات المتحده
والقوى الاجنبيه الاخرى في فرض عقوبات على
الجنرلين والحديث هنا عن قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوه
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف
بحمل التين ذلك حينما اطاح معا بالحكومه
المدنيه سنه 2021
وبدلا من ذلك حاولت الحكومات الاجنبيه
اقناع الجنرلين المتنافسين بالاصلاحات
الديمقراطيه هنا طرح السؤال كيف يمكن جعل
من يحمل المال والبنادق يتخلى عن السلاح
خبراء اشاروا الى وجود عقبات امام الحكم
المدني منذ البدايه فحتى اذا كان المجتمع
الدولي خاصه الولايات المتحده فعلى كل شيء
بشكل صحيح كان من غير الواضح ما اذا كانت
الثوره ستنجح في المقابل كان واضحا ان
الجيش سيحتفظ بالسلطه فحكومه حمدك املت في
ان يتمكن السودان من تعزيز مكانته والقيام
بحزمه اصلاحات بدعم دولي خاصه من الولايات
المتحده لكن هذا لم يحدث ليعود هذا البلد
الى نقطه ما قبل الاطاحه بالبشير بل واصبح
على شفا حرب اهليه بلال البجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
في الوقت الذي اغلقت فيه ودمبا اغلقت
ودمرت المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه بجنوب
دارفور غربيه السودان بسبب القتال بين
الجيش والدعم السريع لم يغلق الفاتح حسين
عيادته بل حولها الى غرفه العمليات
للمصابين من المدنيين والعسكريين اذ اجرى
عشرات العمليات الناجحه
بحيث جبل الشرقيه مدينه نيالا يسكن الفاتح
حسين تقني العيون الذي حولته المعارك بين
الجيش والدعم السريع هنا بجنوب دارفور الى
جراح يستخرج المغذوفات والرصاصه من اجساد
المصابين جراء المعارك
في واحده انضرب في العين
واقامه جابوه لقيت المخزون موجود في الجبن
فقمت انا زلت المخزوف من الجفن بكل براعه
يعني
الحمد لله رب العالمين توفيق من ربنا وبعد
ذلك الناس طبعا يعني قاعد في العياده
بتاعته وشغال
وكل المستشفيات مقفله وكل العيادات مقفله
يعني والضرب كان كتير جدا جدا وكثيف
والناس بقت بعدك تتوافد للعياده
بامكانياتهم محدودتين في هذه العياده
الصغيره ازرع الفاتح اكثر من ثلاثين عمليه
ناجحه يستند فيها على خبره اكتسبها من
دراسه اسعاف حالات الكوارث الطبيعيه
والحروب في وقت سابق بعد ذلك طبعا الناس
بقت تشيل الناس تجيبها المساله ويقولون
ياخذ عسكري
وكلهم يعني اسعفناهم
عندنا
السكان هنا يمتدحون ما يقوم به من خدمه
انسانيه وكيف انه اصبح طوق نجاه للعديد
ممن طالتهم المغذوفات والرصاص والطائش
يعني
مرات بكون نايم زي ربع ساعه عشان ياخذ
راحته يعني يقول لنا
الامكانيات في الوقت الذي تعرضت فيه عشرات
المراكز باقليم دارفور للتخريب والدمر لا
سبيل للمصابين سوى التمسك بهذه الاجتهادات
الفرديه
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد لحظات روسيا
تستعد لاحياء يوم النصر لكن بشكل مختلف
هذا العام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه بعد
ثلاث سنوات وتاجيل المحاكمه ما يقارب ست
مرات القضاء العراقي يصدر حكما باشهر قضيه
اغتيال حيث اصدرت محكمه جنايات الرصافه
حكما بالاعدام شنقا حتى الموت بحق المدان
احمد حمداوي عويد المتهم بقتل الخبير
الامني هشام الهاشمي بدوره اعلن المركز
الاعلامي لمجلس القضاء الاعلى انه بامكان
المدام استئناف هذا الحكم
القضاء العراقي يصدر حكما باعدام قاتل
الخبير الامني هشام الهاشمي بعد جدل
ومحاولات بلغت 10 مرات متتاليه لتاجيل
النطق بالحكم المركز الاعلامي لمجلس
القضاء الاعلى قال في بيان مفصل ان محكمه
الجنايات الرصافه اصدرت حكم الاعدام بحق
المتهم احمد حمداوي عويد لارتكابه جريمه
اغتيال الخبير الامني هشام الهاشمي في
السادس من يوليو عام 2020 امام منزله عن
سبق اصرار وترصد وان الحكم ياتي وفق قانون
مكافحه الارهاب رقم 13 لسنه 2005
عمليه اغتيال الهاشمي اثارت ردات فعل
شعبيه وادانات دوليه بسبب ما وصفتها
منظمات انسانيه وحقوقيه انها جريمه متعمده
لاسكات صوت الهاشمي المنتقدي لتصرفات
جماعات المواليه لايران توعدت بتصفيته
اللحظات الاخيره للهاشمي كانت مساء السادس
من يوليو كان يهم بالتوجه الى محطه
تلفزيونيه بسيارته الخاصه للحديث عن
انتهاكات الميليشيات وتنفيذ الهجمات
الارهابيه قررت جهه المسلحه تقول الانباء
انها ميليشيا حزب الله العراقي ارسال
مسلحين لقتل الهاشمي امام منزله بمنطقه
زيونه وسط بغداد حاول احد المسلحين فتح
النار على الهاشمي وهو داخل سيارته ففشلت
المحاوله ليشهر مسدسا ويفرغ رصاصاته في
صدر الهاشمي سارع اولاده وبعض الاهالي
لاسعاف الهاشمي ونقله للمستشفى لكن الرجل
رفض انفاسه الاخيره وفارق الحياه قرب
منزله ومع محاولات جهات سياسيه وحزبيه
التغطيه على حادثه الاغتيال لمده عام كامل
اعلن رئيس الوزراء السابق مصطفى الكاظمي
في يوليو من عام 2021 القبض على قتله
الهاشمي بعد وعود قطعها امام وبث
التلفزيون الرسمي اعترافات المتهم وهو
ضابط برتبه ملازم اول في السادسه
والثلاثين من العمر
سمارتي يمكن ارفع
خبر الحكم بالاعدام علاقات الخبير والمحلل
الامني هشام الهاشمي حتى اجتاح اسمه
الخبير الراحل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لان العديد من العراقيين لم يشكو غليلهم
وطالبوا بالكشف عمن يقفوا وراء الذي اغتال
الهاشمي امام منزله بدوره راى مدير مركز
بغداد للرؤيا والدراسات محمود النجار
بتغريده على حسابه في تويتر ان قاتل
الهاشمي سيعدم ولكن لم يتم الكشف عن الجهه
التي اعطته الاوامر
من عمان ينضم اليها المحلل السياسي
العراقي رعد هاشم استاذ رعد اهلا بك معنا
اصدر الحكم باعدام قاتل هشام الهاشمي ولكن
السر يكمن وراء من اعطاه الاوامر لماذا
حتى الان لم يعلن عن الجهه
تحيه طيبه لكم المتابعين وشكرا للاستضافه
يعني واضح هناك يعني توريه وتمويه وتغطيه
على
الجماعات المسلحه التي يعني بادرت قامت
بهذا الفعل الجرمي ولكن يعني هذه
التغطيه المتبادله ما بين الجهات السياسيه
والميليشياويه ربما يعني يعني تعترض كثيرا
الموجبات القانونيه والتحرك القضاء
لمعالجه هذه القضيه الخطيره طبعا القضاء
ولكن اقله السبب الذي جعله يقتله هل تحدث
عنه
جميع تابع الاعترافات قبل اكثر من سنه
ونصف يعني 2021 اعتقد
وكان المقتطع الاعترافات كلها ربما كان
هناك
محاولات يعني التغطيه على الجهه الفاعله
ربما اكثر من جهه يعني هي قد تورطت في هذا
الموضوع ولا يريدون ان يكشفوا عنها ربما
الاعتبارات لا يريدون ان يستثيرون كانت
حكومه الكاظمي في وقتها الكاظمي ايضا هو
مهدد من الجهه ربما التي استهدفت هذا هذا
الشخص هذه الشخصيه الممتازه واعتقد كان
هناك يعني محاوله من قبل الحكومه الكاظمي
لتهدئه المواقف وترك الموضوع الساحه كلها
امام القضاء لكن يعني ليس من مهمه القضاء
كشف تفاصيل عمليه اغتيال سياسي هذه القضيه
قضيه راي عام هذه المساله ربما تحلها
الحكومات فيما بينها تحلها الاحزاب فيما
بيننا لكن لم يشفي غليل العراقيين ومحبي
وعائله هشام الهاشمي هذا الحكم اليوم
لا بالتاكيد هناك قلق من عباره استئناف
انا لا اعلم حينما تحصل محاكمات بحق
الدواعش يحصل فيها استثناء او او يعني
استئناف للاحكام يعني هي هاي ماده اربعه
ارهاب قانون مكافحه الارهاب اللي مثل هكذا
قضايا اعتقد ليس فيها استئناف لكنه والشخص
ايضا عسكري يبدو ايضا من الشرطه لا نعلم
اذا الشرطه ايضا يعني
كافحوا على بعد هذه القضيه الخطيره
صفوفهم وطردوا بعض هذه العناصر ومن ضمنهم
عناصر ثبت تتعاطهم للمخدرات يعني بحسب
اعترافات وزاره الداخليه لا طرق لاصلاح
وتطهير لهذه البنيه العسكريه والتي لها
ارتباطات على ما يبدون عن ميليشيات كما
ثبت لنا هو ضابط في الشرطه وميليشياوي على
كل يعني كان المرحوم هشام الهاشميه السرني
ويسر زملائي الاخرين تخوفه الخط من خطوره
التهديدات التي تصله من جماعات مسلحه ومن
ضمنها كتائب حزب الله يعني حتى نختصر
المسافات او الزمن على الجهات الحكوميه
التي تتحرج من هذه الجهه الميليشياويه او
تلك هو كان يقول لنا ولدينا يعني حتى هذه
حتى هذه المخاطبات فيما بيننا لازمنا
نحتفظ بها هو يقول اعذرني
[موسيقى]
الان الى تركيا حيث قال الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان ان مليون و700,000 تركي
شاركوا في تجمع الانتخابي اليوم في
اسطنبول وقال اردوغان ان اسطنبول لها
اهميه كبيره في الانتخابات مشيرا الى انها
لو اختارته فسيفوز بالانتخابات الرئيس
التركي وعد بتخصيص موارد الطاقه او الدفاع
في الفتره المقبله لزياده رفاهيه الاتراك
كما اتهم الصحافه الغربيه بتدبير مؤامرات
ضلاميه ضد تركيا على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
ايضا مشاهدينا ايام ويتوجه الناخبون في
تركيا الى صناديق الاقتراع للادلاء
باصواتهم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه المقرر اجراؤها في الرابع عشر
من مايو الجاري الاحزاب السياسيه تستعد
لاستخدام تكتيكات جديده لاقناع الناخبين
بالتصويت لها اما حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم يناقش السبل استماله الناخبين
المترددين في كواليس حزب العداله والتنميه
تسود بعض التقديرات مفادها ان السباق بين
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان والمرشح كماله
شديد المنافسه او ان اردوغان متقدم بفارق
نقطتين فقط تقديرات الحزب تقول انه سيخسر
حوالي ما بين واحد الى اثنين بالمئه من
اصوات الناخبين لصالح حزب الديمقراطيه
والتقدم وحزب المستقبل المنتمين للتحالف
الامه فيما يعوض هذه الخساره ناخبون اكراد
محافظون لن يصوتوا لصالح حزب الشعب
الجمهوري الذي يتزعمه كمالك
ما قد تعيد اردوغان الى
يشدد حزب العداله والتنميه ايضا على اهميه
استخدام اردوغان لغه تصالحيه في الاسبوع
الماضي قبل الانتخابات والتي قيل انها قد
تؤتي ثمارها في حسم نتائج الانتخابات
في كواليس حزب العداله والتنميه هناك من
يتوقع فوز اردوغان بالانتخابات في الجوله
الاولى وان كان بهامش ضئيل وهناك ايضا من
يعتقد ان فرصك لشدار اوغلو اردوغان
متعادله ولا يمكن استبعاد خوض جوله
انتخابيه رئاسيه ثانيه
انتخابات الرئاسيه وبرلمانيه ربما تكون
الاهم في تاريخ تركيا الحديث وبعد 20 عاما
يبدو ان اردوغان باتا على حافه الهاويه
وفق تقرير لصحيفه ساندي تايمز فلاول مره
يواجه اردوغان احتمال الخساره حتى في
معقله القديم طرابزون ومن المتوقع ان
يتراجع الدعم الذي كان يتحصل عليه الرئيس
المنتهيه ولايته لكنه لا يزال يحظى بدعم
ضخم بين قوائده الانتخابيه حيث ينظر اليه
باعتباره رجل دوله يحمل على عاتقه مسؤوليه
تحويل تركيا الى قوه عالميه لكن شعبيه
اردوغان تاثرت بعوامل عده بينها نهجه
الاقتصادي وفضائح فساد فضلا عن تعامل
حكومته مع الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب البلاد
في فبراير الماضي تقرير الصحيفه لفت ايضا
الى ان ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه في تركيا
باتا يغطي على كل شيء حيث سجلت معدلات
التضخم في البلاد ارتفاعا بلغت نسبته
في اكتوبر وتمت عنصر اخر مؤثر في هذا
السباق الانتخابي بحسب الصحيفه هو ان نحو
خمس الناخبين الاتراك هم دون سن 25 ولم
يسبق لنحو نصف هذا العدد التصويت من قبل
في وقت تشير استطلاعات الراي الى ان نسبه
كبيره من هؤلاء الناخبين الجدد تعارض نظام
الحكم السلطوي الذي ينتهجه اردوغان
فكر في التصويت الكليتش دار اوغلو لاني
غير راض عن اوضاع البلد خاصه في المجال
الاقتصادي بمعزل عن المسار السياسي ارى ان
الاقتصاد بات بحاجه لتغيير الحزب الحاكم
وبراي ان افضل مرشح لذلك هو
لن اصوت لرجب طيب اردوغان باختصار لا داعي
لتجربه المجرب من جديد حاله البلد من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه واضحه
لكمال
كليتشا وصادقا لذلك توقعوا انه سيتفهم
حاله البلاد والفقراء
يعمل بجد زعيم جيد وقوي سنقف خلفه دوما
رجل صالح ولذلك ساصوت له اراه الخيار
الجيد للبلاد ساصوت
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي ولكون حزبنا يدعم
مرشحه تحالف الامه
لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي لاني احب صلاح
الدين دملتاش واحب افكاره لا احب افكار
الاخرين
[موسيقى]
الى روسيا الان حيث هناك استعدادات ليوم
النصر هذا العام تختلف عن صديقاتها بسبب
التغييرات التي فرضتها المخاوف الامنيه
والحرب على اوكرانيا على هذه المناسبه
الوطنيه والتابع
تحضيرات لا تعرف الليله من النهار في
روسيا استعدادا لاحياء يوم النصر الثلاثاء
المقبل
ساحات نابضه تضوج بفعاليات ذكرى الانتصار
على النازيه قبل 78 عاما
مشهد هذا العام سيكون مختلفا ليس فقط بسبب
الحرب في اوكرانيا بل بسبب مخاوف امنيه
خصوصا بعد استهداف الكريم الذي عبث بمسرح
الاحتفال المركزي
موسكو ليست وحدها التي تحيي يوم النصر بل
كل الاقاليم التابعه لها
لكن هذا العام مختلف حيث تم الغاء
الاحتفالات في سته اقاليم لاسباب امنيه
وفق مسؤولين
اخر الالغاءات كان احتفال مقاطعه بريانسك
التي تبعد
451 كيلو مترا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه
الغاء من نوع اخر اشارت اليه صحيفه
الجاردين البريطانيه اذ الغى الرئيس بوتين
ولاول مره مسيره الفوج الخالد التي ترفع
فيها صور قتلى روسيا في مواجهه النازيه
المسيرات العسكريه ستكون خاليه من الجنود
المتعاقدين وستقتصر على مجندين بسبب الحرب
اما في بعض الاقاليم سيكون على المنظمين
الابداع لاطفاء مظهر طبيعي وفق الصحيفه
ما تمر به روسيا منذ اكثر من عام غير
الكثير من المسلمات حتى احتفالات يوم
النصر رغم كل ما تحمل من رمزيه في وجدان
كل روسي
[موسيقى]
اظهرت لقطات فيديو مصوره باستخدام الطياره
مسيره اظهرت منظر مجموعه من المباني
المدمره في الضواحي الغربيه لمدينه
الاوكرانيه وتشهد هجوما مكثفه من قبل قوات
جاردنر الروسيه السابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في اخبار الساعه لدينا بعد لحظات استطلاع
واشنطن بوست واي بي سي يظهر تراجع شعبيه
بايدن بعد قراره الترشح لولايه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الساعه باعلان
الجبيل نيته في الترشح لولايه ثانيه شهدت
شعبيته نتائج عكسيه بايدن لم يعد مدعوما
الا ب 38% من الناخبين بعيدا عن ترامب
الذي لامست شعبيته الاربع واربعين بالمائه
حسب استطلاع الراي نشرته واشنطن بوست
شعبيه بايدن عند ادنى مستوى منذ انتخابه
عام 2021
كشف استطلاع من الراي اجرته واشنطن بوست
واي بي سي تفوق ترامب على بايدن بست نقاط
مئويه في سباق الرئاسه
كما اظهرت نتائج الاستطلاع ان شعبيه بايدن
تراجعت بست نقاط مئويه بعد اعلان ترشحها
وبخصوص السلامه العقليه والقدره على قياده
البلاد حصل بايدن على تاييد 33% فقط من
الناخبين
في المقابل يعتقد 64% من الذين تم
استطلاعهم ان ترامب في صحه جيده تؤهله
لولايه ثانيه شعبيه بايدن انخفضت في صفوف
الديمقراطيين حيث يفضل 58% منهم دعم مرشح
جديد للانتخابات
[موسيقى]
كشف تقريرنا لمجله ان قضيه الهجره في
الصين خيار لا يطرح ابدا عند دراسه الحلول
الممكنه لسد نقص العماله في البلاد في وقت
لا يتجاوز فيه عدد المهاجرين في البلاد
المليون شخص او
0.1% مقارنه بعدد السكان البالغ ما يقرب
من المليار ونصف المليار نسمه
[موسيقى]
لم يبقى سوى التفكير
بعناوين اخبار الساعه
دول العربيه قرارا خطوه مقابل خطوات تعيد
دمشق الى الحضن العربي بشروط والجامعه
العربيه ترحب بمشاركه الاسد بالقمه اذا
رغد
الجامعه العربيه تدعم مبادره السعوديه
وامريكا لوقف النار في السودان
مساعدات سعوديه من 100 مليون دولار للشعب
السوداني
القضاء العراقي يصدر حكما بالاعدام علاقات
الهشام الهاشمي ودعوات لمعرفه من مصدر
الاوامر
استطلاع لواشنطن بوست واي بي سي يظهر
تراجع شعبيه بايدن بعد قراره الترشح
لولايه ثانيه
اشكر الطيب المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]